[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour un nouveau numéro de
Parlement Hebdo à l'émission qui revient
sur les temps forts de l'actualité de la
semaine au Parlement et nous accueillons
aujourd'hui Xavier yacovelli bonjour
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
sénateur des hautes scènes memrees du
groupe rdpay la majorité présidentielle
et vous êtes par ailleurs vice-président
de la commission des affaires sociales
au Sénat beaucoup d'actualité pour vous
et à la une cette semaine le projet de
loi immigration qui arrive à l'Assemblée
nationale un débat à haut risque se
dessine pour le ministre de l'Intérieur
géralde de dararmanin il doit trouver
une majorité de députés pour adopter ce
texte et pour l'instant les députés les
républicains y sont opposés le Sénat a
adopté le budget de la Sécurité sociale
pour 2024 dans une version remagnée la
majorité de droite sénatoriale a estimé
que le texte proposé par le gouvernement
allait encore creuser les déficits les
sénateurs ont également voté une
proposition de loi qui reconn connait
l'injustice de la criminalisation de
l'homosexualité en France entre 1942 et
1982 la majorité de droite c'est
néanmoins opposé à des réparations
financières l'Assemblée nationale se
penche donc à son tour sur le projet de
loi immigration le texte a été voté par
les sénateurs dans une version durcie il
comprend deux volets l'un sécuritaire
l'autre sur l'intégration avec notamment
la question de la régularisation dans
les métiers en tension le coût d'envoi
des a été donné cette semaine avec
l'audition de Gérald dararmanin
Stéphanie des pierre pour géralde
dararmanin c'est un double défi il doit
convaincre une partie des oppositions
sans perdre le soutien des députés du
camp présidentiel alors pour cette
première audition à l'Assemblée
nationale le ministre de l'Intérieur
défend l'équilibre de sa loi donc
simplification drastique des
procédure intégration avec exigence
d'intégration notamment par la langue
travail de fermeté extrêmement fort
contre les délinquants étrangers voilà
le sature du projet de loi le texte
largement durci par le Sénat fait
désormais bondir la gauche pour la
France insoumise ce projet criminalise
les étrangers même les socialistes pas
totalement hostile au départ sont
sceptiques on devait examiner un texte
méchant avec les méchants et gentil avec
les gentils on se retrouve avec un texte
méchant avec tout le monde à l'inverse
le rassemblement national dénonce le
laxisme et à une vague de régularisation
de
clandestin avec la droite la pomme de
discord c'est l'article 3 supprimé et
réécrit par le Sénat géralde Darmanin ne
veut pas revenir à la version initiale
pour ne pas braquer la droite
sénatoriale mais il doit convaincre ses
propres troupes d'accepter des
modifications le rapporteur du texte
pense avoir la solution je proposer à
notre commission avec
cèguepporteur que nous puissions
une solution qui ne soit ni le droit
automatique général et absolu qui pose
une série de difficultés réelles ni le
pouvoir discrtionnaire du préfet tel que
le Sénat a pu le prévoir mais pas sûr
que cela suffise à convaincre les
républiquains côté assemblée seul une
réforme de la Constitution assurera une
pleine effectivité de ce texte redonnera
à la France le droit d'accueillir sur
son sol qui elle veut et la la
possibilité de se protéger d'une
immigration massive et subie qui porte
atteinte aux intérêts fondamentaux de la
nation géralde Darmanin n'est qu'au
début des négociations pour éviter un
493 les débat en commission commence
lundi alors Xav yakovelli sincèrement
quand on voit les positions des uns et
des autes on se dit que ces mission
impossible pour convaincre tout le monde
est-ce que vous croyez que Gérald
daranin va réussir à trouver une
majorité sur ce texte explosif vous
savez moi je crois à la capacité de
géraldin de convaincre et de faire en
sorte de trouver un compromis sur un
texte qui est important et qui est
attendu par les Français il l'a démontré
d'ailleurs au Sénat tout le monde nous
disait et la presse en premier nous
disait que il était impossible qu'on
puisse faire céder et trouver un
compromis avec leslr sur la question de
la régularisation des travailleurs dans
les métiers entention forc de constater
queeffectivement on a supprimé l'article
3 mais on l'a réécrit dans l'article 4
bis et donc on a bien dans ce texte ce
qui sort du Sénat on a bien le mot
régularisation des travailleurs qui va
pas plire au députés LR je vous parle de
la capacité de Géral lmanin de trouver
un accord je vous rappelle qu'il y a
aussi des progrès qui ont eu lieu
puisque en commission il y avait la
suppression des articles 2 5 et 8
notamment sur le durcissement des
sanctions contre les employeurs qui
employaient des des des travailleurs
sans papier ça avait été supprimé par la
majorité LR en commission ça a été
réintroduit après discussion avec le
gouvernement et le gouvernement a réussi
et geréral a réussi à convaincre
effectivement la majorité sénatoriale de
réintroduire ces dispositif dans la loi
donc vous voyez moi je crois à la
capacité du ministre de l'intérieur de
trouver un compromis encore une fois
c'est une loi qui est attendue par les
Français les Français attendent cette
loi attendent qu'on puisse à la fois
durcir notre politique migratoire avec
ceux qui n'ont pas vocation à être sur
notre territoire de pouvoir aussi
expulser ceux qui commettent de la
délinquence dans notre pays et puis
mieux intégrés et notamment comme l'a
dit le ministre de l'Intérieur intégré
par la langue avant tout sur l'article 3
qui prévoit cette régularisation des
travailleurs sans papier dans les
métiers ention article 3 qui est devenu
article 4 bis au Sénat est-ce que selon
vous il faut garder la version
sénatoriale de cette mesure qui prévoit
des régularisations à la discrétion du
préfet avec un contrôle strict cette
version elle vous convient ça va
permettre de trouver un compromis avec
les républicains moi j'étais
effectivement sur la version initiale
celle du gouvernement qui était en fait
renforcement la régularisation
automatique mais avec des critères qui
étaient fixés par le Parlement donc
c'était le Parlement qui fixait les
critères de régularisation des MTI en
tention le par le le Sénat a décidé de
retirer des prérogatives au Parlement et
le donner au préfet donc au gouvernement
écoutez moi ça me va bien aussi donc la
version sortie du Sénat me va bien nous
une des lignes rouges et on l'a
réaffirmé dans dans nos discussions dans
notre explications de vote dans nos
communiqués de presse c'est la question
de l'Ame l'aide médicale d'État qui a
été supprimée par la majorité
sénatoriale et et on a l'habitude de
dire que le Sénat corrige les
excentricités de l'Assemblée nationale
et là c'est plutô l'verse on attend que
nosollègues députés puissent
réintroduire quelque chose qui nous
paraî est une faute une triple faute en
fait de la part de la majorité
sénatorale d'avoir supprimé cette aide
médicale d'État alors les députés de
droite et du rassemblement national
estiment que cela va créer un appel
d'air est-ce que ce risque existe avec
ce qui se dessine sur cette loi est-ce
que le RIS sur quoi sur la me ou sur
réularis la
régularisation je pense qu'ils n'ont pas
lu en fait le
texte il a pas d'appel à partir du
moment où on régularise les gens qui
sont déjà sur le territoire et qui
travaillent déjà dans des métiers
entention avec une une condition de
durée dans dans les métiers et sur le
territoire donc il y a pas d'appel d'air
à ce niveau-là donc c'est un faux procès
condition d'être 3 ans sur le territoire
français bien sûr 3 ans sur le
territoire français et dans un méti pas
bénéficier à ceux qui ne sont pas en FR
heureusement heureusement parce que là
effectivement ça sera un appel d'air
mais c'est pas du tout la volonté le but
c'est d'intégrer ceux qui sont déjà sur
le territoire et s tir de cette
hypocrisie aujourd'hui que et d'ailleurs
même le le tissu économique le mdev
demande en fait cette régularisation
pour sécuriser aussi les employ Covelli
les députés les républicains ont dit
qu'ils ne voteraient pas ce texte
notamment à cause de l'article sur les
régularisations même dans la version
modifié par les sénateurs les
républicains finalement est-ce que le
gouvernement avec cette majorité qui est
incertaine sur ce texte doit risquer
d'utiliser le 493 pour passer en force
sur ce texte immigration est-ce qu'il
faut utiliser le 493 sur ce texte
sachant on le rappelle le gouvernement a
le droit à un seul 493 dans cette
session parlementaire on ne le souhaite
pas on le souhaite pas et et moi le
premier je pense si la majorité est
incertaine si la majorité est incertaine
la première ministre prendra les
responsabilités qui sont les siennes
d'engager la responsabilité de son
gouvernement je pense que c'est
nécessaire et mais il va falloir aussi
que les LR explique à leur électorat que
une loi qui est attendue par les
Français on n'est pas sur le principe
des retraites parce qu'on voit bien que
il y a des divergences entre le Sénat et
et l'Assemblée nationale au niveau du
groupe des Républicains mais les
désaccords qu'il y avait sur une loi
comme les retraites qui n'était pas
populaire là on est sur une loi qui est
attendu par les Français donc il 43
populaire bah en tout cas 493 attendu
par par en tout cas loi attendue par les
Français et donc 493 avec la
responsabilité du gouvernement engagé si
on n'arrive pas à trouver un accord mais
le but c'est encore une fois de trouver
un accord avant les fê de Noël et si 493
il y a il y a un risque de motion de
censure elle pourrait aboutir cette
motion de censure estce qu'il y a la
majorité euh pour faire tomber le
gouvernement il va falloir que s'il y a
mention de censure mais on fait de la
politique fiction là s'il y a motion de
censure va falloir queon nous explique
comment la gauche vote une motion de
censure déposée par les républicains sur
une loi sur l'immigration qui durcit en
fait les règles de régularisation va
falloir qu'il soit aussi un peu cohérent
donc moi je pense qu' il est plus
important de trouver un compromis sur ce
texte attendu par les français plutôt
que d'aller jusqu'à une censure ou des
postures politiciennes les députés LR
conditionnent leur vote sur ce projet de
loi immigration à une réforme de la
Constitution notamment sur le
sujet migratoire pardon euh est-ce que
vous êtes favorable pardon à cette
réforme je je suis pas favorable je
pense que ça la porte a été fermée par
le Président de la République sur euh
l'intégration euh et la modification le
référendum aussi sur la question de
l'immigration je pense que le sujet est
clos et qu'on doit pasidée non on doit
pas toucher la Constitution pour tous
les sujet il y a des lois mais il y a
des lois qui sont importantes il y a des
lois qui sont attendues on a un
parlement qui est là pour ça on n'est
pas obligé de de mettre ça dans la
Constitution alors on va passer à un
autre sujet qui vous concerne puisque le
Sénat a voté cette semaine le budget de
la Sécurité sociale pour 2024 la
majorité de la droite et du centre a
remanié largement le texte des hausses
de taxes sur les boissons et les
alluments sucrés ont par exemple été
ajouté par la Haute Assemblée résumé
avec jérum Rabier c'est désormais un
classique le Sénat a largement réécrit
la version gouvernementale pour
finalement adopter son projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale la
majorité de droite et du centre a
commencé comme l'an dernier par rejeter
la trajectoire financière présentée par
le gouvernement et qui prévoit un trou
de la SCU qui passerait de 8,8 milliards
en 2023 à 17,5 milliards d'euros en
2025 un manque de maîtrise rejeté par la
Haute Assemblée trajectoire qui est
proposée elle sera de plus en plus
déficitaire pourquoi parce que justement
on voit que l'assurance maladie coûte de
plus en plus cher alors que les Français
sont de plus en plus insatisfaits le
gouvernement s'est défendu de ne pas
être soucieux des comptes publics et a
renvoyé au Sénat la responsabilité
d'avoir lui aussi aggravé ce déficit
avec de nombreuses modifications
coûteuses constater qu'à l'issue de ces
débats le déficit de la Sécurité sociale
se retrouve aggravé de plus de 1,3
milliards d'euros par des dépenses
supplémentaires et et des moindres
recettes sur les sur ter la réforme de
la tarification à l'activité la jugeant
mal préparé ils ont voté une
consultation du Parlement en cas
d'ugmentation des franchises médicales
ou encore adopter le principe d'une
somme forfaitaire à payer en cas
d'absence à un rendez-vous médical
baptiser taxe lapin et comme chaque
année côté recette le Sénat a voté
plusieurs taxes sur les produits trop
sucrés ou contenant trop d'additifs
contre la vie du gouvernement les
additifs de toutes sortes sont à
l'origine de maladie chronique avec des
vraiment des complications sévères ça
vous nuit à votre santé à votre confort
de vie et vous nous dites on va s'en
prendre au pouvoirs d'achat mais on s'en
prend au pouvoir de vivre là la version
sénatoriale a été votée uniquement par
des membres des groupes LR et Union
centriste qui se font peu d'illusion sur
ce qui sera conservé au final dans les
arbitrages du gouvernement Rais quand
cré Xavier yakovelli à nouveau il n'y a
pas eu d'accord entre députés et
sénateurs sur ce budget de la S et jeud
le gouvernement à l'Assemblée nationale
est à nouveau passé en force à sur ce
sur ce budget de la SC bah qu'est-ce qui
se passe le gouvernement ne dialogue
plus avec le Parlement alors il est pas
passé en force il est pas passé en force
il a utilisé un élément de la
Constitution qui engage la
responsabilité du Gouvernement sur une
question budgétaire et vous savez il y a
rien d'exceptionnel et c'est comme ça
dans toutes les collectivités
locales l'opposition vote contre le
budget la majorité vote pour le budget
et quand on a une majorité relative il
est pas anormal queon engage la
responsabilité du Gouvernement sur un
budget de la Sécurité sociale ça veut
dire qu'il y a plus de dialogue ben il y
a eu un dialogue on a je peux vous dire
que moi pour avoir assisté à à toutes
les séances du Sénat sur le projet de
loi de finance de la sécurité soci oui
mais le Sénat est majoritairement dans
l'opposition au gouvernement donc on
voit bien qu'il y a un dialogue avec
l'opposition que les oppositions à
l'Assemblée nationale ne souhaitent pas
dialoguer et fasse de l'obstruction
systématique qui pousse le gouvernement
effectivement à engager sa
responsabilité par le 493 c'est une
chose mais le dialogue a eu lieu avec
les oppositions au Sénat alors en tout
cas la majorité de droite du Sénat s'est
opposé à la hausse des dépenses de santé
prévu par le texte du Gouvernement les
sénateurs de droite estiment que cela va
mettre encore plus dans le rouge les
comptes de la Sécurité sociale Xavier
acovelli est-ce qu'il faut trouver des
économies dans notre système de santé
comme le demande la droite sénatoriale
mais moi je suis complètement d'accord
il faut trouver des économies
effectivement on ne peut pas
continuellement vivre sur un endettement
important et un déficit important de de
notre financement de la sécurité sociale
mais je note juste et ça a été rappelé
par le ministre et je suis d'accord avec
lui sur ça c'est que à la fois la droite
sénatoriale demande de faire des
économies refuse d' de voter long d'AM
pour pour 202 objectif national des
dépenses maladie refuse de voter cette
trajectoire et dans le même temps il
vote plus d'un milliard 3 de dépenses
supplémentaires ou de recettes moindr
donc on voit bien qu'il y a une espèce
d'incohérence une course à l'échalote de
celui qui fera le plus de propositions
de de de dépenses supplémentaires et en
même temps à la fin on dénonce le fait
que on a eu un déficit important sur la
sécurité sociale donc je pense que on
mériterait d'avoir un peu plus de
cohérence sur la droite sénatoriale sur
à la fois les les propos tenus par la
commission des finances et à la fois
Infiné le vote de de la Ve assemblée
alors dans le débat vous avez proposé
Xavier yacovelli une hausse de taxes sur
les boissons et les aliments sucrés vos
amendements ont été votés par une
majorité de sénateurs mais le
gouvernement n'y était pas favorable il
a mis en avant le fait que ça pouvait
désavantager les les familles les plus
modestes est-ce que c'est le cas oui
alors c'est c'est des taxes
comportementales effectivement j'ai fait
plusieurs amendements deux principaux un
sur les sodas très sucrés et un sur les
aliments transformés avec des additifs
de de sucre et pourquoi parce que
aujourd'hui on est dans une situation où
y compris chez les jeunes beaucoup chez
les jeunes d'ailleurs on a une
augmentation du surpoids ou de l'obésité
et c'est principalement dû à un taux de
sucre dans nos aliments qui aujourd'hui
n'est pas nécessaire et qui empoisonne
en fait la la santé de de de nos jeunes
et de nos familles et donc moi la les
proposition c'était à la fois de
surtaxer parce que je pense sincèrement
que les boissons sucrées ne sont pas
essentielles à notre quotidien et que le
fait de taxer un peu plus les boissons
sucrées nous permett peut-être de
réduire cette consommation les taxes
comportementales ont fonctionné et je
prends l'exemple du tabac plus on
augmente le tabac moins on a de
consommation et sur la question des
produits sucrés notamment dans la
l'agroalimentaire et des produits
transformés cé aussi une incitation pour
les industriels à baisser leur taux de
sucre parce que la question ce n'est pas
seulement le gras c'est avant tout le
sucre qui aujourd'hui provoque l'obésité
et et et le surpoids et donc on voit que
un certain nombre de produits
d'industriels ont réduit leur taux de
sucre pour pouvoir être un argument
marketing en fait pour vendre vous voyez
on a moins de sucre donc vous pouvez
acheter nos produits donc ça veut dire
que les industriels sont capable de le
faire et donc la proposition que j'avais
faite c'était une surtaxe pour les
produits nutriscoré euh assez haut et
ceux qui ont un bon score au nutriscore
puissent avoir une taxe moindre et
pourquoi parce que ça permet justement
de soutenir ceux qui ont le moins de
moyens et qui puissent que que le le
Bien Manger ne soit pas seulement bloqué
par des questions financières alors des
hausses de taxes sur les produits sucrés
ont été voté mais pas sur l'alcool vous
le regrettez
oui je je je le regrette alors vous
savez la question de l'alcool dans les
territoires de notre pays est toujours
très compliqué et et donc nous c'est
vrai qu'on on dépose un amendement avec
la sénatrice Guillotin et euh du RDSE et
le sénateur jaumier du Parti socialiste
euh pour effectivement augmenter alors
pas augmenter les taxes c'est c'est
justement toute la différence c'est de
faire en sorte qu'il y ait un prix
minimum pour l'unité d'alcool
c'est-à-dire pour éviter que les
produits euh le le vin par exemple
étranger qu'on qui sont qui arrivve en
vrac et qui est vendu euh en en cubi par
exemple à moindre coût puisse être un
prix très très peu cher ce qui incite à
la consommation notamment des plus
modestes et surtout des jeunes et donc
c'est ça en fait c'est une question de
santé publique avant tout que ça soit
pour la taxe sur les soldats la taxes
sur les produits transformés ou la le
minimum le minimum le prix minimum pour
le pour l'alcool c'est avant tout une
question de santé publicque alors vous
avez voté autre chose vous avez voté une
taxe lapin pour pénaliser financièrement
tous ceux qui n'honorent pas leurs
rendez-vous médicaux c'est une mesure
juste pour vous est-ce que la méthode du
bâton ça marche pour responsabiliser le
le citoyen P qu'il faut il faut qu'il a
deux il faut qu'il a la pédagogie
expliquer je pense que c'est important
d'expliquer que c'est plusieurs millions
d'euros qui coûtent à la sécurité
sociale sur des des rendez-vous qui ne
sont pas honorés par par les patients et
puis c'est aussi un temps il y a je sais
plus je crois il a il y a 600000
personnes qui n'ont pas de médecin
traitant qui n'arrivent pas à trouver de
de de rendez-vous avec généralistes
c'est aussi pour une un moyen de lutter
contre les déserts médicaux c'est-à-dire
que aujourd'hui le temps qui est
consacré à des rendez-vous qui ne sont
pas honorés et ben en fait c'est du
temps qu'on pourrait consacrer à des
gens qui ont vraiment des pathologies et
qui ont besoin d'avoir un rendez-vous
médical donc avoir une taxe il faut à la
fois de la pédagogie et à la fois aussi
le bâton pour ceux qui ne respectent pas
les règles communes le gouvernement
réfléchit Xavier cové une hausse des
franchises médicales c'est-à-dire une
hausse du du reste à charge pour les
assurés de la sécurité sociale notamment
sur les dépenses en terme de médicament
également sur les consultations
médicales en période d'inflation ce
serait une bonne idée cette hausse du
rest ta charge pour les assurer alors
c'est une piste qui a été lancée
effectivement par le ministre Aurélien
Rousseau au mois d'août sur lequel
j'avais déjà réagi parce que sur le
principe moi je ne suis pas opposé et je
pense que c'est ça peut être utile parce
que encore une fois ça ne concerne pas
les femmes enceintes ça ne concerne pas
les mineurs et ça ne concerne pas non
plus de fait même si c'est pas noté noir
sementi les maladies chroniques puisque
en fait aélien Rousseau le ministre de
la Santé a permis aussi dans les
arbitrages même si c'est pas
complètement finalisé il avait dit une
augmentation de 50 centimes
effectivement pour les médicaments euh
mais en gardant la franchise qui existe
déjà c'est-à-dire c'est pas quelque
chose de nouveau une franchise de 50 €
par an c'est-à-dire que nous tous on a
une franchise de 50 € par an c'estàd
au-delà de cette franchise on ne paye
plus les 50 centimes supplémentaires et
donc de maintenir cette franchise de 50
€ par an c'est-à-dire que tous ceux qui
sont malades chroniques des maladies
longue duré ne sont pas concernés
puisqu'ils dépassent déjà les la la
barre des des 50 € de franchise les
femmes enceintes et les mineurs ne
seront pas concernés c'est pour lutter
aussi contre la
surmédicamentalisation je sais pas si ça
si ça se dit exactement comme ça mais en
tout cas il y a une consommation trop
importante aujourd'hui de médicaments en
France qui ne sont pas nécessaires et
donc on a besoin c'est plus d'économie
pour la sécurité sociale et c'est aussi
avant tout une question de santé
publique alors dernier sujet de cet
entretien le Sénat a voté également
cette semaine une proposition de loi
pour reconnaître l'injustice de la
criminalisation de l'homosexualité entre
1942 et 19 82 en France on le rappelle
le régime de Vichy avait interdit les
relations homosexuelles incluant une
personne majeure sur le plan sexuel mais
mineure sur le plan civil c'était une
forme de discrimination la majorité de
droite du Sénat a voté ce texte mais
s'est opposé à des réparations
financières pour les personnes victimes
on va écouter sur ce texte et bien
l'auteur de cette proposition de loi le
sénateur socialiste Hussein Bourgi qui
évoque et bien les souffrances de ces
dizaines de milliers de personnes qui
ont été condamnées à cause de leur
homosexualité pour toutes les personnes
condamnées le prix à payer fut lourd si
les faits réprimés étaient assortis
d'amende ou de courtes pein de prison
ces condamnations même légères
constituaient des tâches indélébiles
pour les personnes concernées ces
sanctions pénales allaient de paire avec
leprre social
l'ostracisation le rejet des condamnés
par leur famille elles on trraînent
également bien souvent leur licenciement
ou la ruine de leur carrière
professionnelle ces pertes sociales
morales et financières ne sauraient être
évaluées ces peines infamantes ont
marqué àe des existences elles firent
voler en éclat des vies et des familles
ces condamnations poussèrent au suicide
certains malheureux acculés à la mort
par une presse peu scrupuleuse qui étalé
leur identité ou publier les photos des
déventures des commerces dans lesquels
il travaillaient aucune loi ne sera
hélas en mesure de réparer ce préjudice
mais nous pouvons tâcher de nous y
employer et c'est bien l'objet de cette
proposition de loi xavovelli au final la
Major té de droite et du centre du Sénat
a reconnu la faute de la République dans
cette criminalisation de l'homosexualité
mais a refusé des réparations
financières pour les personnes qui ont
été condamnées il en reste une centaine
en vie encore aujourd'hui vous regrettez
ce ce